Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get into the Friday mailbag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
We sometimes will include Facebook posts or
messages or YouTube comments or tweets or.
It's all fair game if you're commenting publicly,
but info at David Pakman dot com is the place.
The email we are starting today indeed with
a youtube comment.
It comes from Robert.
Robert says, my president Trump, my president,
who I voted for, who took care of America
first left an economy with a 1.4% inflation.
Everybody was working that on the first day.
Like I told everybody, I studied this.
I already knew the election was going to be
stolen.
He's going to shut down the Keystone power
plant.
Gas is going to go up.
He's going to open the border.
This country is self-destructive.
Everything happened itself engineered.
It's all intentional and you know that.
And then there's more.
But I would be very, very much oxygen deprived
if I continued.
It's going to be hard to talk this guy out
of this stuff at Thanksgiving.
Okay.
That that I can say for sure.
And this type of stuff is everywhere.
It's quite literally everywhere.
I don't know what we do with it.
I don't know how we deal with it.
And we recently spoke to former Scientologist
Mike Rinder, who said, oh, no, no, no.
Cult beliefs are they are very, very stubborn
things.
They are very resistant to change, I guess
we would say.
Good luck to Robert a Dan in.
And again this one of the things that happens
is when we do a livestream, lots of people
who have no clue who I am or about our show
will be watching, which is great thanks to
the algorithm, you know, new people.
But many of them are shocked that I'm on the
left and I don't just shut my mouth the entire
show.
And Dan wrote in about the Abrams DAB eight,
that's DAB 80 and said, Pacman, I was trying
to hear and understand the viewpoints being
espoused tonight.
But due to your unnecessary progressive commenting,
I decided to change the channel and not even
give Abrams a chance.
Right.
My opinions made it so that you decided that
you were supporting Brian Kemp.
Incredible amount of power that I have.
Dan goes on to say, I think that your viewpoints
are poisonous and not indicative of most Americans.
Not really accurate, actually.
Yes, I am with Trump and garbage like transgender
should not be taught in schools.
Again, I.
So what does it mean to teach transgender?
I don't know.
They're all repeating it.
I pray that your children will have a more
conservative viewpoint on subjects that are
internal to homes and not society as a whole.
No prayer needed.
I think it is quite likely that my children
will have beautiful, empathetic, open minded
perspectives.
Not very much aligned with Dan.
But thank you.
And yes, if you just want the debate only,
there are many, many other places where you
can find that.
Ozanne wrote in.
With tears in his eyes, he says.
Did Mike Pillow ever send you pillows to try
out?
I heard their normal pillows.
Nothing special.
Also, are you going to appear on his insane
show?
I seem to remember him inviting you on while
he was arguing with your Facebook followers.
Love the show.
Yeah.
So no on the pillows.
Pillow insisted during the interview.
I'm going to send you these pillows.
You can.
They're going to be the best thing ever.
And I said, listen, I think you're completely
wrong about voter fraud, but if the pillows
are good pillow, I'll tell the audience.
And he said his assistant would follow up.
His assistant never followed up.
No one followed up.
There are no pillows on the way.
He also did not invite me onto his show.
So it may may come as a shock to some of you.
He may not always be telling the truth.
I'm starting to suspect, Danielle wrote in
about Tulsi Gabbard.
And this is a this is a good question, David.
At what point do you think Tulsi Gabbard started
plotting out her Dem exit, her Democratic
exit?
I do have to admit I was bamboozled by her,
although I didn't vote for her.
Of course, you're right.
And in hindsight, I see she was and is obviously
a grifter.
I just wonder if as far back as 2016 or before
she had already been planning this, that she
had been positioning herself to be a Democrat
who would ultimately leave the left because
the left left her.
After all, that's how the right wing pundits
have used her, showing her off as a Democrat
who they can depend on to criticize other
Democrats much the way they did with Dave
Rubin.
Both of them took advantage of that to position
themselves for financial gain and notoriety
before ultimately becoming full throated right
wingers.
What do you think, Daniel in San Francisco?
I do not think this was something Tulsi planned
ahead of time.
Tulsi is an opportunist and a grifter and
as such.
I mean, guys, think about it.
I understand going from, you know, I really
think we should have super high taxes on the
rich to saying.
Speaker 3: Actually.
Speaker 1: I think 37 as a top tax rate is
fine once you make above 400 K, even if you
make a billion buck.
Like, I can understand that.
I don't agree with it, but I can understand
that.
But Tulsi went from being a Democrat by name
anyway.
In the Democratic primary to over the weekend,
she was at a rally to end child mutilation.
And of course, your guess is as good as mine.
What that means?
Does that relate to vaccines?
Does that relate to gender affirming care
for trans people?
I don't I don't know what child mutilation
they're referring to, but it's a whacked out
event.
It's just opportunism.
It's where.
Who's interested in me?
Democrats were not interested in Tulsi.
She got one 2% of support in 2020, in the
primary, and just nobody cared because it
was all so boring.
Same thing with Trump, right?
I mean, it wasn't if Trump did his shtick
and said I'm running in the Democratic primary
haha.
Maybe he makes one debate and then he's gone.
Trump's not winning a Democratic primary.
It's the wrong audience for him.
He needs people willing to, you know.
So he ran as a Republican.
Similarly, the stuff, of course, he's doing
works way better on the right and she's going
for it.
So, no, I think she did not plan this far
ahead.
It was just when she ran in Hawaii, the way
to become a member of Congress was run as
a Democrat.
And I think, Tulsi, if anything, probably
has very flexible political views or none
at all.
And it's just all a grift.
Bill Rhoden And says, David, I have a question.
Can Trump run in 2024?
That is the 22nd Amendment says no one can
be president who's been elected twice.
Trump won in 2016 and he claims he won 2020.
Therefore, the fact he refuses to concede
the 2020 election means he cannot run in 2024.
Bill, of course you're making sense.
But no, this isn't going to work because they've
already figured it out this way.
And I'll tell you, it is.
They are right about this, even if you believe.
That the will of the people was for Trump
to win.
The States transmitted their electoral votes
such that Biden got to 70 and Biden is the
president.
So certainly Trump can still serve.
And I know that I get the idea right.
Trump says, I ran twice.
I won twice.
Well, if you won twice, you can't run again.
You can't serve more than two terms as president.
And Trump has only served one term.
So I wouldn't I wouldn't focus on that too,
too much.
Kevin wrote in and says, Hey, David, first
off, I watched your recent video showing the
absolute insanity of these right wing political
hopefuls.
How these people have gotten this far is beyond
me.
Second, do you think these people pronounce
Kamala Harris's name as Kamala instead of
Kamala?
Because it sounds more brown, for lack of
a better clarifying term, it seems to me they
have a vested interest in making their opponents
seem more other.
Regardless, if they turn around and spit out
melting pot, this ingenuity right after.
Thanks for your show, David.
Yeah, I mean, listen.
I'm not saying Republicans in their heads
go, hey, you know what?
If I say Kamala instead of Kamala, it sounds
more black, so I'm going to do it.
I'm not even necessarily saying Republicans
think to themselves I'm going to disrespect
Kamala Harris by mispronouncing her complicated
nonwhite sounding name.
I think it may even be operating at a subconscious
level, but there is no doubt.
That part of the reason they can't just say
Kamala or won't say Kamala is because Kamala
Harris is a nonwhite woman.
Subconsciously, overtly, we could argue.
I don't know.
But there is no doubt that that is a factor.
Mayank wrote in about the Gish gallop and
says, David, sir, you spoke about how to combat
the Mike Lindell style Gish Gallop debate
strategy, which was super interesting.
It made me wonder if you have any tips on
how to learn to deploy that strategy in a
debate yourself.
I also wonder what happens if both parties
use that strategy?
Incoherence, I assume.
Yeah.
So as a reminder, Gish Gallop is when you
say ten or 12 different things in a debate,
it's impossible to follow all of them.
It's just like throwing a bunch of crap at
the wall.
Right.
So, you know, during these 2022 debates, we've
seen the topic of, I don't even know the southern
border come up.
Rape in a Republican will go.
Joe Biden has opened the southern border and
is letting people pour in to these Democrats
sanctuary cities.
The border was fixed under Trump.
The wall was built and we had the strongest
border ever.
And they're bringing in fentanyl.
Actually, they like to say fentanyl.
Fentanyl.
The fentanyl is coming in from China and it's
coming through the southern border.
And now it's in Halloween, Candy, in Britain.
Right.
And.
If it's not.
Oh, you get 30 seconds to rebut that, right?
If you get 30 seconds to rebut that, the way
many of these debates are structured, you
can't do it.
The debates are mostly structured in a way
where you can't fight the Gallup.
The best way to have a fighting chance when
you have 30 seconds to rebut all of that stuff
is to say, listen.
There were so many lies there.
I can't rebut them all in 30 seconds.
If you give me more time, I will.
But the wall wasn't built.
There is no open border.
The fentanyl is right.
And you just go.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
He or she is lying to you.
That's your best shot in a 32nd response format
in a more extended conversation at Thanksgiving
or whatever.
What I like to do is say, listen, you just
mentioned 12 different things.
We can't talk about 12 different things at
once.
We just we just can't.
Are you willing to to talk about these things
one at a time so we can actually figure out
what's going on?
Because I want to know what's really going
on.
And if you can get the other person to commit
to that, then you have a fighting chance.
But in the debate format, it's impossible
because you can't do it in 30 seconds.
Malcolm wrote in and said, This is why Democrats
lose.
Hey David, I watched your excellent stream
of the Georgia Senate debate.
There was a difference of expectations.
Warnock proving he should continue as U.S.
Senator.
Walker proving he could express coherent thought
in the English language.
I waited for Warnock to deliver the killing
blow.
He let Walker express pro-life sentiments
without bringing up the abortions he has paid
for.
And let him take a stand on many issues he
doesn't understand or has no answer to.
From crime to health care to education.
Why do you think mainstream Democrats can't
fight Republicans on their own level?
I don't want him to dismantle democracy or
perpetuate lies.
But I do want them to fight Republicans on
their own ground by fighting hard.
Can we fix this?
I was also disappointed.
So on the abortion thing, I think Warnock
just said he considers Walker's personal life
in the abortion stuff out of bounds.
So I think what Warnock decided not to talk
about that, but there were many opportunities
for Warnock to say, Ladies and gentlemen,
my opponent has no idea what he's talking
about.
He just said about 100 words.
There is no meaning to what he is talking
about.
Here is the truth about ABC.
If he can't even explain to you that he understands
this, how can we empower him to be one of
100 U.S. senators?
It is dangerous, ladies and gentlemen.
The Republicans have done something dangerous
and disrespect irresponsible here.
He didn't he didn't go that way.
I don't know why.
And maybe his thought is it would come off
poorly.
I don't know why, but I was not thrilled with
that performance or many others.
Mark Kelly's performance wasn't good.
It's depressing, and I'm sure there's an explanation
as to why.
I'd like to hear it and evaluate it for myself.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
Sign of it.
Join Time.com.
Don't miss it.